Hey, what's going on guys. This is Rob.
This is just to let you guys know I'm going to be selling Rob core rings here in
the next couple of weeks. I found a way to sell them an unlimited quantity.
So I'm only going to sell them about 20 rings at a time.
They're going to be first come first serve. Right?
So you can announcement in a video at the beginning of the video.
So keep your ears out, make sure you guys check the videos out,
but I'm going to make an announcement at the beginning of the year, you know,
and say, Hey guys, Rob court rings are for sale.
Make sure you guys check the link down in the description. And, uh,
and then once they're gone, they're gone until I reopened it again. And, uh,
until I restock and then make more rings available,
it will go in this fashion forevermore when I'm, you know, depending on how the,
the turnout to this is never stopped selling Rob port rings and just kind of
keep it on there and just sell them forever and ever, and ever,
and just do it in like, you know, sections do it.
Like I might do it one week and then wait two or three weeks and do it again.
Maybe I'll do it once a month and just kind of do it randomly over the course of
the month. I'm not entirely sure either way,
we're going to start selling Rob port rings.
So I figured I would make you guys aware of it.
So you guys will have your chance to buy them and yeah, let's start the video.
Okay. So this is going to be a unpopular opinion here, right?
This is going to be an unpopular opinion,
but I feel like this is what Tom King's Batman run should have been.
Like the more I get into this, the more I'm kind of like, I like this more,
but I, I did enjoy Tom King's Batman run, but I feel like this is great.
The way it's being done waves being handled with Bruce Wayne.
And I'll tell you guys why once we get towards the end of this video,
but this initially picks up with ghost Hunter. I'm sorry.
Ghost maker tracking down Bruce Wayne. Right now,
remember we still don't know anything about this guy, right?
We still don't know anything about ghost maker, but this deals with the past,
right? And this has kind of a cool thing.
This is a cool concept where we get to see the early days of Batman.
This is not uncommon now for those of you guys,
you don't know what I mean in the, the,
the period after the events of prices on infinite earths and BC's experiment
with whether or not Batman could continue to hold a title. Post-crisis right,
because they almost canceled him in the sixties and seventies.
We ended up getting Batman year one, right after,
after the dark Knight returns and Batman year one was kind of a retelling of
that man's origin story. But following that,
we got what can largely be considered to be a lesser known line of comics called
tales of the dark night.
But tales of the dark night were a series of stories that were told by different
writers.
It was kind of a rotating cast of a writers and artists that basically dealt
with the early events of Bruce Wayne's life, right? Like either the,
the time when he led up to becoming Batman,
but mostly the time after he became Batman, right?
Just kind of an immediate interim period.
And what this did is it kind of fleshed his character out with different
adventures, his relationship with Superman, why it is they're good friends,
different things along those lines. And so what we get here,
it's kind of that in a more condensed form, right?
In the sense we're basically seeing the introduction of ghost maker when he and
Bruce Wayne were younger.
And what ends up happening here is he basically tracks him down to a kind of
desert. And we can tell that there's almost,
I wouldn't really say there's a friendship between these two,
but there seems to be a mutual respect. Right?
And that's kind of the shaky thing about how James Tinian does this.
They don't really hate each other, but they don't really like each other.
They don't disrespect each other,
but they don't really have a whole lot of respect for, I don't,
I don't really know exactly how this kind of relationship can be characterized.
Maybe it's just one that's highly competitive,
but given the things that are going on right now between ghost maker and Batman,
there doesn't really seem to be a lot of love loss there.
But the whole thing about this is that, uh,
that there's this kind of discussion.
Wayne says that today's his anniversary of when his parents died.
And that's why he doesn't want to fight ghost maker. At that point in time,
he says, just leave me. I'm training out here. And that the response is built.
Smoker is no you're brooding, right?
That doesn't count is that the whole point of this training session is to be
conscious of every grain of sand.
Bruce Wayne realizes ghost makers already done this.
And that's one of the general consensus of his character is that he is always
seemingly one step ahead of Batman. When it comes to training that in, you know,
in a, in a,
a one-on-one confrontation ghost maker will almost always win because everything
that Bruce Wayne's learning now, he already learned, right?
He's just that far ahead of him. Now, again,
we don't know where all this originated from. We know that he came from Gotham,
but we don't know this is like a childhood rival.
That's just continued on all the way up to the here and now we don't really know
a whole lot about what's going on here. Right?
We don't really have the full on origin of ghost maker.
And so we're just kind of left to these little flashbacks that we get from
tenure here and there, they kind of give us an indication of what's going on.
But one of the things that he says here is that, uh,
that he kind of apologizes to Bruce. And Bruce's kinda like why me?
I didn't really think that you felt things like that. They,
you wouldn't really care that my parents died. And his response was like, no,
I don't. I don't really care that your parents die.
I'm apologizing to you because you're going to fail.
But you allow your emotions to rule you.
And because you have emotions that makes you weak, you have to be emotionless.
You have to approach something like this, not caring about people,
because it's the only way to truly function in this chaotic world.
And so what you end up doing is jump forward and Johnny Ford to the here and now
where we left off with the last,
the last story where you had ghost maker facing off against Batman.
Now the cool thing about this is in, in, in all honesty,
I think ghosts maker is a better Batman than Batman, right? Like I really,
really, really think he is one of the first things that happens.
You've got Oracle, right? You've got Barbara Gordon.
Who's using all of her intelligence abilities to try to read and on everything
that goes to maker's doing. And the response of Batman is don't. If you do that,
his, his ghost net will literally just like work into your system. And it'll,
it'll, it'll start destroying all your computers, right?
The whole purpose of the ghost net is to make sure nobody can track it, right?
It's a cannibalized computer algorithm.
It'll find your computer system and eat it apart. The other thing is like,
this guy is not to be trifled with right.
This guy is serious business indicating he's got a lot of resources.
The funny thing about that is that in this kind of conversation between Batman
and ghost maker, ghost maker kind of responds and saying like,
you used to make fun of the name that I had in that. Interesting.
You said you didn't need a mask or a pseudonym to fight crime in Gotham,
but look at you now you're Batman. Like how clever is that a man dresses, a bat,
good job, Bruce Wayne, you sure showed me. You know, it's, it's one of these,
these funny little things, right? One of these,
these funny almost where he's kind of taunting him. He's like,
how long was it when you came to Gotham that you became Batman?
Were you here for like a week? Were you here for like maybe a month,
but somewhere along the line,
you realize how stupid that ideology was and you would need some kind of an
identity in order to basically shield yourself or to, to, to scare people.
And that's kind of, what's,
what's nuts here is because Batman basically says it we've been beating ghosts
makers since they were 20, which may very well be true.
But ghost maker responds in saying like, do you know what I've done? And,
and just the time that I've been here and I've been here for only 12 hours,
do you know what I've done?
I leak the criminal activities of 14 different district judges just to your
Gotham Gazette, right?
You're in you're inept are basically taking him into custody right now.
I solved a string of homicides, but your same cops couldn't solve.
And now they're putting the killer into Arkham asylum.
And I sent the FBI the location of six shipments of heavy artillery from Santa
Prisca. I did all of that before I even left my plane. Right.
This is how much better of a Batman I am venue.
I solved all these crimes and you haven't done it yet. If you haven't done it,
if you're so capable and you haven't done it yet,
why haven't you done it now from there? Of course it leads to, you know,
indicates he's going to go directly after count Hunter.
And that's when Batman basically tells him get out of here. Right.
And so it basically kind of boils back down to Batman versus ghost maker again.
And that's, what's kind of awesome is he basically tells Batman, like,
you're failing. You are, you are failing superhero.
Like you're a guy who's trying to, you know, keep Gotham under control,
but you're failing in almost every conceivable way, right?
Like you have sadistic villains who get back onto the street and they kill just
as many people, if not more than they did the last time.
And you hand them over to a justice system that, you know, cannot control them,
but you hope that it can one day and then they get out and the whole cycle
repeats itself, right? If you really wanted to keep Gotham city safe,
then you would kill them all.
You would kill all those various sadistic criminals that you have out there.
And then you would say, that's enough, right?
Because you're not out of control of your emotions.
Surely you can objectively look at the things your villains had done and come to
the rational conclusion that they should die and then create a line in the sand
that you simply just don't cross. Like that's,
what's interesting there because it does create like these really,
really interesting philosophical, moral limits,
because insane that I guarantee you as clear as, as sure as the sun will rise,
people will automatically come out with a cookie cutter argument. Well,
if you change this line in the sand, kill, change that line in the sand. Right.
And it'll just kind of keep on sort of creating those arguments. Right.
But from there you switch over to, to, to Harley Quinn, right?
And Harley Quinn is here talking to a plant that kind of poison Ivy have she
grabbed out in the park somewhere. Now I may be a little bit behind here.
I don't think I am. As far as I'm aware,
I think poison Ivy is still dead following the events of heroes in crisis.
Honestly, I don't remember the ending of that story. All that well,
to be quite Frank, honestly, I don't really think most people do.
I thought heroes in crisis was great until you got about to the end.
It was a cool, interesting ending, but it was kind of like, you know,
but nonetheless, if I'm wrong, correct me. Right.
Cause I did a little bit of poking around and I couldn't really find a
definitive answer. But the, the whole point of this is that poison Ivy is,
is like, it's really kind of keeping up a mento of her. Right?
Which all points to the idea that poison Ivy is dead.
But common Hunter shows up out of nowhere, right.
And immediately starts going towards this check.
Now there is an origin of count Hunter that we can cover it.
If you guys are interested. Honestly,
the reason why I haven't done it yet is I wasn't really sure you guys would be,
but we can cover it if you guys are interested. If you guys want to see that,
let me know down in the comment section, but Holly Quinn,
this is the funny thing about Harley Quinn, right? Historically speaking,
Harley Quinn kind of muses to herself about this idea that she's more or less
lived her life based on what everybody else wanted.
And that was the significance of poison Ivy's role in her life.
And that's why you see her in such a way that when clown Hunter shows up,
she's just kind of like, you know,
I'm not going to kill you because in years past you would have,
right in years past, she would have been with the joker.
A joker would have said, kill him for her.
She's kind of doing her own thing right now. Of course,
she manages to get the upper hand on him,
but not before he reveals to her that his weapon is called the bat bat,
which is kind of an amazing name. Right. I guarantee you,
people are going to be cost playing once Comicons open, back up.
I miss Comicons and I miss hanging out with you guys at Comicons.
I miss that man. You guys are so fun to hang out with.
I just met with a fan Andrew yesterday here in Columbus and bought him lunch.
I thought I left my wallet at home.
It turned out it was in my car the whole time. So I was kind of panicking. Like,
am I really going to hang out with a fan? They're going to have to buy me lunch.
Like, I feel like I feel terrible if that happens. But uh,
I found a wallet in the car,
but I bought him lunch and we hung out and just like for like two and a half
hours, three hours, and just like hung out and talked about nerd stuff.
So I miss, I miss hanging out with you guys.
I miss like seeing you guys spending time with you guys. I miss that,
but I feel like once con's opened back up again,
people are going to cosplay as clown Hunter. Somebody is,
and they're going to have the bat bat and it's going to look awesome.
But you know, he kind of gets the upper hand on Harley quintuple, rarely.
But the funny thing about clown Hunter is for all the zealousness that he has
and for all the candor that he has,
he is still painfully inexperienced.
He's just a really off kid who believes he's doing the right thing,
getting out there and tearing stuff up.
He's very indicative of Bruce Wayne in the early days of Batman, right.
Just flying by the seat of his pants and needing a bit of a guiding hand.
But the funny thing is in the midst of all this, once Carmen Hunter subdued,
Batman comes crashing in through the window with a sword in his back.
And Holly Quinn's of course, Tanya clown Hunter. And, and,
and it's kind of one of these things where like this,
this sword is sitting in his back, she's like,
do these sorts of cool and clown and ghost makers like, yeah, man,
they really kind of are. He's like, I presume you're Holly Quinn, right?
You're the boy's target. And she's like, are you some kind of an assassin?
You know? And he's like, I'm not an assassin. I'm a crime fighter.
I'll call the ghost maker. And she's like, that's a dumb name.
And he's like, this city sucks. And like attacks and just like subdues her.
You know, it was like, man, this city sucks. Wolfville well, well you're stupid,
you know? And then like knocks her out.
So it was obvious that that ghost maker is still very immature in some ways.
But then this is when Batman pulls the rug out from under it.
And this was one of the things, and this is,
this is one of the things where I would kind of challenge Batman on this.
And what he basically says here is that the serial killer that was handed over
to, to, you know, Arkham asylum that Batman had that basically CA uh, Cassandra,
Canada been tracking that guy for quite some time in order to find out like
where he worries stores his trophies, right?
Because it took a trophy from every single person that he killed.
And the idea is that now the families aren't going to have that they're going to
have to live with hearsay.
They'll never really know how many victims he had when it came to the,
the judges that were busted. They were all working for tiger shark, right?
A well-known villain well-known super-villain in, in DC comics.
And that ghost maker just destroyed. What is N w what is an essence,
an entire Rico case Rico, of course,
being racketeer influenced and corrupt organizations act right,
is a part of the, uh, the organized crime act of 1970s. Really in 1970,
it was designed to combat organized crime.
Something that the federal government created when they implemented prohibition.
Right. But he's kind of like,
like these guys were all being all being surveilled, right?
Like I was going after tiger shark. I didn't care about the judges.
We would take them down too, but I was going after him. Right.
If we bust the judges and we have all this evidence,
we can intern BAS tiger shark under the Rico laws,
because he basically instructed them to commit all these crimes, you know?
And then when, uh, when he's talking the Santa Prisca Shipman, he's like,
I infiltrated that shipment six days ago.
And I replace all the weapons with faulty shells and was waiting to take down
their buyers here in Gotham city. Now,
all this evidence that Batman presents is really designed for the purpose of
saying I was playing a much bigger game than you thought I was.
But the funny thing about this is that this is not necessarily Batman as ghost
maker remembers him. This is Bruce Wayne.
Who's learned a few things in the early days of Gotham.
He would've shown up just like that. Right. He would have,
he would have reacted the exact same way that ghost maker did,
but in his early adventures in Gotham,
he would've just sort of taking down major guys were taking down, you know,
over the criminals happened to be it wasn't until the various experiences of
Bruce Wayne got in saying, okay, we have things like the organized crime act.
And we have, you know, section nine Oh one a, which is the Rico statute.
Like we have all these different things that are out there.
I can use those at my disposal and help build cases against the bigger guys,
right? Because if I take a drug dealer off the street,
there'll be another one tomorrow. But if I take off the guy,
who's actually supplying drugs to the drug dealers,
then that puts a huge wrench in the works of the people out there who are trying
to run these great, big, huge criminal empires.
But the crazy thing about that is that at the end of the day,
ghost maker still has the one up on Batman.
And the reason why is because he looks at clown Hunter and he says, okay,
so like maybe I was a little, I jumped the gun a little bit, right?
Maybe I was overzealous.
And I was in such a desire to prove to you that I was better than you.
Then maybe you got the upper hand on me on these things. So here's my question.
This kid count Hunter killed 24 people in the midst of jokers last attack.
That's more than three times.
The number of people that are serial killer had killed and you're protecting
him. Why is this kid not in Arkham asylum? Why is he not there?
Why is he not locked away?
And the response of Batman is because if we throw them in Arkham asylum,
where if we do them in black, a prison,
the guards will agree with what he was doing. And they would enable him.
And he was like, didn't, we should kill him.
And Batman's only response is he's 17 years old, right.
He watched his parents die in front of him.
He's a by-product of his experiences. But at the end of the day,
the question that you kind of have to ask here is at what point does Batman stop
making excuses for people? At what point does that happen for those of you guys,
if you ever get a chance, there is a, well,
at least there was a Hungarian philosopher named Agnes Heller.
She actually passed away a little while ago, but she had a really good book.
And I want to say, it's called the theory of feelings.
And she talks about why people commit crimes. As she says,
crime crimes only ever really happened under one of three circumstances.
There's crimes of profit crimes of passion and crimes of compulsion that a crime
of profit is a,
is a crime where a person commits it and doesn't care about the consequences.
The profit does not have to be monetary.
It's simply just a thing a person gets in return for committing that crime.
Maybe it's some kind of self satisfaction, some kind of enjoyment.
They get out of it, whatever the case happens to be, right?
So like they enjoy killing people and it,
and it satiates a happiness inside their body to do that right inside their mind
in order to commit those crimes. And the answer is a clown Hunter.
It is one of these things where he's like,
I find satisfaction in taking these guys out because I believe they're bad guys.
The second thing is a crime of passion.
A crime of passion is one of these things where like you come home,
like you find your man in bed with another woman,
you just freak out and stab him to death, right.
It just happened spur of the moment. And, and it's just, you know,
that's where they,
they call going into like a psychotic rage or something like that.
You couldn't control yourself. A blackout.
You hear about cases like that sometimes.
And then a crime of compulsion is you're driven by it,
but you cannot help yourself.
The joker is somebody who commits crimes out of compulsion, right?
He's compelled to do things that will get Batman to chase after him,
depending on how you want to slice it.
That's why he's been written consistently over the years is because he commits
crimes under one of those three circumstances, profit, passion, or compulsion.
But for the, for the character of count Hunter, he knows what he's doing.
He understands that he's killing people.
He gets the rhyme and reason behind it because he understands the nature of his
actions and the gravity of his actions. You can't make excuses for him.
He can't say, well, I mean, you're only 17. That kind of a thing. No,
you knew what you were doing. And then in turn, you, you treat them accordingly,
right? Which means he goes under arrest.
He goes into the justice system and in turn,
maybe sentenced to execution or something like that.
And the instance of what ghost maker is saying here is if they hand them over to
the justice system.
And Batman's concern is that the guards will agree with him and they'll enable
him. And he'll in turn,
make the justice system even more corrupt than the only way to STEM that tide is
to kill him, but just take them off the board,
which is not an unreasonable argument to make.
But regardless of how you decide to slice it at the end of the day,
the responsive ghost maker with everything going on here is that fine, right?
If this is going to be your attitude,
but you're constantly going to make excuses for everybody out there who commits
a crime, how it's somehow not their fault and they can be redeemed.
Then I will make Gotham better right now on the surface.
This is hand wavy on the surface. This is, Oh my God.
We've seen this story a million times before, but not like this with Bain,
he took over Gotham city and just turned into a giant criminal enterprise,
right. And was using like villains as a means to run the, run, the show,
running the town with joker, he just turned the entirety of Gotham into madness.
This is a cool story to see a person who comes along,
who legitimately could actually make Gotham better, who is able to,
to become a full measure where Batman is a half measure. And then in turn,
we get to see what happens after that.
Would Gotham actually be a better place under the rule of ghost Hunter?
Or would it be just like this fascist totalitarian kind of place?
We don't really know.
And I feel like James Tinian wouldn't take it in that direction. If he did.
I feel like it'd be a travesty.
I think the best thing he could do is to actually make Gotham city an inherently
better place, right? Like criminals are just executed, right?
They're just killed. Not, not like baseline drug, dealing criminals, but like,
this is a district ones, right? People who kill, who kill other individuals,
right? Like, you know,
they're just executed on the spot and that's basically it,
if it's done in that way and any other way, right. That, that,
that I'm not considering here.
And Gotham actually becomes a much better city and it's better under ghost maker
than it ever was under Batman. That would be an amazing story.
Not because it would give us room to get rid of Batman,
but because of the fact that it would show us what things Batman could use from
that to make Gotham better versus what he does that makes Gotham worse.
It'd be a great dissection of the nature of Batman and whether or not he is
actually good for Gotham city. It's a great philosophical concept.
So with that being said, guys, we're going to bring this video to an end.
If you are new here to come and explain to make sure you guys have the sub
button to become part of the Rob court. If you guys enjoy this video,
make sure you drop a light. Now we'll catch you all there.
Purse
[inaudible].